mr. mayor thank you for agreeing to do
this extra doughnuts you enjoying the
bus I am yeah it's starting to feel like
a second home you once you hit bus
status that's kind of a sign of like
yeah we've some level of success and as
I understand it everyone from Steven
Spielberg and Glenn Beck and Hillary
Clinton and MIT Romney have been on this
vehicle specifically sounds like this
bus has a very bipartisan history but
I'm trying to pull it a little more in
our direction let's start by talking a
little bit about health care you have a
new plan out Medicare for all who want
it but how is it different from the
affordable care act as it currently
exists so the affordable care act is a
marketplace of private insurance options
the idea of Medicare for all who wanted
is a public alternative Medicare for all
who want it means we take a version of
Medicare and we make it available for
every American I believe that this will
be a better option than any of the
private plans out there I also believe
Americans ought to be able to decide for
themselves and so the way we have this
setup is this Medicare for all who want
it will be available to everybody but if
for some reason you prefer to stick to a
private plan we're not going to order
you to abandon it we're not going to
shut down the private insurance industry
we are going to create an alternative
that I think most Americans are going to
prefer and if people like me are right
then it's going to be a pathway to
Medicare for all without somebody in
Washington having to guess how many
years it will take for that transition
to happen well let the American people
decide so the ultimate end goal is a
government-run health care system I
think that's that it's going to lead
toward everybody or almost everybody
opting into that public plan but you're
not required to so the important thing
to me is not whether or not the
government's the main insurer the
important thing to me is that everybody
get care it doesn't matter to me
in principle who's giving it it matters
to me how Americans are able to get it
now as I understand it your plan would
automatically enroll people in a public
option if if they're eligible that's
right if you don't have private coverage
should they be forced to do that what we
need to make sure
that everybody has coverage because
otherwise that creates a cost to the
system when you go into an emergency
room and you don't have coverage
somebody is picking that up and it's
usually a combination of crushing
medical bills and debt for the patient
and or a hospital absorbing that cost
this way but that can't happen you can't
fall through the cracks and that
benefits all of us and helps keep costs
under control
when undocumented immigrants be eligible
for this plan yes they would be eligible
to buy into the plan pay a premium and
get covered and what happens over time
to those thousands of people who work
for those private insurance companies if
the goal is to eventually eradicate the
private health care insurance industry
well even in countries that have not
just a single payer but socialized
medicine there's still a private
insurance industry as well at least in
most countries so I don't expect that
the private industry ever goes away
completely I do expect that over the
years it shifts and more people working
in health care will either be involved
in care itself instead of administration
or will be involved in other parts of
the industry but there will be years for
this to develop in recent days you and
some others have been calling out
Elizabeth Warren for the fact that she
will not admit that her Medicare for all
plan would require a tax increase for
middle-class Americans does your plan
require a tax increase for middle-class
Americans no we can fund what I am
proposing without raising taxes on any
but perhaps the top two percent now I do
believe that our tax code needs to be
fair there are corporations and very
wealthy Americans who should be paying
their fair share and aren't and we're
going to adjust that not just in order
to fund our health care plan but in
order to fund the needs of this country
it's not punitive it's not unreasonable
it's just what we need in order to make
sure that we can move forward as a
country but everything that I proposed
from health care to education to climate
change will be fully funded because I
believe it's important that what we do
reduces or at least does not increase
the deficit Republicans have talked for
a long time about debts and the deficit
and it turns out based on their behavior
when they're empowered that they don't
care that means that if Democrats don't
start to care about this
nobody will and as maybe just it's just
my perspective as a the youngest
candidate in the field but I'm worried
that a lot of these financial time bombs
that have been set by both parties but
especially by Republicans right now that
those time bombs will go off on my watch
or during my lifetime well speaking of
Republicans let's say you get elected
president there's still a Democratic
House you have to put up with at least a
Republican Senate how do you convince
Republicans to support something that in
essence starts to chip away and you know
at the current system which they already
have issues with well the good news is
the overwhelming majority of the
American people favor this approach as a
matter of fact most of the things that
we are for in this campaign and in my
party have very strong American majority
behind them but that argument hasn't
worked on virtually any issue in recent
years the Democrats would argue you know
well the American public's will it's
well okay but you still have a
Republican Congress doesn't want to work
with you on well first of all I think
it's important to have a nominee with
coattails because I refuse to accept
that a Republican Senate is inevitable
and the best strategy by far for dealing
with Mitch McConnell is for him to not
be in the majority anymore that being
said in the event that we're dealing
with a Republican Senate I do think that
a very good use of that big airplane
that comes with the Oval Office is to
fly it into the home state of a senator
who is blocking something like
background checks that 90% of Americans
want or who is trying to take away
health insurance from Americans or who
is blocking a minimum wage increase or
paid family leave and remind that
senators voters of what they're doing
because there's also going to be an
election coming up in 2022
on the flip side your plan creates a
large role for the government to play in
health care but progressives would say
not large enough how do you convince the
more liberal members of your party to
support this kind of a plan it's simple
if Medicare for all is ideal then why
would you need to command Americans to
accepting mine is the best of all worlds
it creates this Medicare for all who
wanted option but it does it without
ordering
anybody to go over to it before they
want to and if as progressives we are
right that this is the best option then
the American people should be able to
decide that for themselves I don't know
what my competitors to the left are
afraid of in giving people that choice
we talked a little bit about the state
of the race last night a few others on
that I think you mentioned and I know
it's been highlighted by others that
have only one in five likely
caucus-goers so far has said they're
sold they've made a decision they're
ready to go how do you convince everyone
else over the next 130 or so days that
you're the guy they should vote for well
they need to see you in action and so
you're gonna see in addition to the
national conversations that I'm having
in places like the Democratic candidate
debates you're gonna see me on the
ground here in Iowa directly making the
case to voters you know in these early
states they want to not only read about
what you're planning to do but kick the
tires a little bit get the sense of the
kind of person you are especially with
so many Democrats with largely similar
values I think people are looking not
only for a set of policies but for a
kind of leader that is going to lead us
in a very very different place than this
current president is and this is my
opportunity to show as well as tell what
kind of leader I would be for the
American people you've seen this
situation with Ukraine and the president
and former Vice President Biden play out
over the last few days the biting
campaigns been made hay of it they're
already sending fundraising emails
saying see this just proves the
president is most scared of running
against the former vice president I'm
curious do you think your party is ready
to stomach having another nominee who
would face questions whether they're
proven or not of family members who have
business overseas look the president is
going to go for the lowest blow that he
can with whatever Democratic nominee he
faces and it's hard even to predict the
depths that he will go and if there's
not something for him to take advantage
of he will make something up so the at
risk of sounding quaint I think what we
ought to do is put up the nominee that
we think will make the best president
because I think that gives us the best
shot of
having voters of varying backgrounds and
values decide to support our candidate
and by the way that's how we usually win
when we overthink this and get to
strategic think about what candidate
will do these things in the process of
other voters that we don't agree that's
what we usually come up short we win
when we put forward the candidate we
think is the most inspiring and the most
prepared to lead us forward in your view
has the former vice president explained
enough
what Danner didn't go on with either
himself or his son in the Ukraine at
this point I'll leave it to him to talk
about all of those things what I will
say is that this isn't the last time
we'll see unfair attacks from the
current President on Democrats and by
the way the president has made a
shocking confession let's just be very
clear the president has confessed to
wrongdoing and in light of that shocking
confession every congressional
Republican ought to go on the record and
clarify whether they condemn or support
what he has done and on that point
you've been pushing house speaker Pelosi
on the issue of impeachment and whether
or not it's time to do that in your over
the weekend she sent a letter
essentially telling her colleagues that
if the president doesn't cough up more
information on this it will quote take
us into a whole new stage of
investigation is she moving fast enough
in your view on impeachment I'm gonna be
honest she knows a hell of a lot more
about strategy on guiding a House
Democratic caucus than just about any of
us and so I respect that she's got a
strategy and a strategy that takes into
account the need to show that we've
exhausted alternatives and the need to
gather the right kind of support what
I'll say from the outside looking in is
that in in terms of checks and balances
I think it's very clear that the house
has a responsibility to stick up for the
rule of law I think that's what they're
trying to do we also know what the
Senate is gonna do about this which is
nothing at all all the more reason that
we need to at least get every Republican
senator and House member on the record
as to whether they condemn or endorse
the wrongdoing perhaps criminal
wrongdoing by this president but a year
view he should be impeached
he should but that's almost an academic
question at this point right in my view
he should be defeated and that's the
part that I actually get to have
something to say about because I mean
you feel that way other Democrats out
here certainly feel that way but a
majority of Americans still aren't there
so is it really worth pursuing if a
majority of the country is telling
Congress don't go there I don't know
that a majority of Americans care very
much that they not impeach any more than
a majority of Americans care that they
do for every question I get about this
from a voter there's probably ten to a
hundred times I get this question from a
reporter the the reality is voters want
to know how their lives are going to be
different and I don't think there's
tremendous angst among most voters
either way on that particular procedural
question in the house
folks want health care they want
immigration to be fixed they want wages
to go up they want their kids to be safe
in school and they want a president who
doesn't make their blood pressure go up
and that's what I can deliver well let's
talk about how things might be a little
different
in terms of foreign policy were you
president this situation between Iran
and Saudi Arabia the president is now
sent or ascending at least some military
personnel to Saudi Arabia to help out is
that the right move in the current
circumstances it may well be required
the question is how do we take control
of the current circumstances so that
they don't keep escalating look right
now we've got an unstable situation that
has been destabilized by the American
president and the Middle East has a way
of being unstable all on its own without
any help from the White House what we
see now as a consequence of a chain
reaction that began with the u.s.
withdrawing from the jcpoa the nuclear
deal is that things are headed in the
wrong direction tensions are escalating
we've done almost nothing toward
resolving the civil conflict in Yemen
which is spilling over because it's a
proxy fight between the Iranians of the
Saudis and we continue to have an energy
policy which makes us more subject than
we should be to the internal struggle
for regional security superiority among
two players Saudi Arabia
and Iran neither of which is exactly
operating according to American values
which begs the question the Saudi Arabia
even deserve US military assistance in a
situation like this well I don't think
the us-saudi relationship is really
built on shared values
I think it's built on a certain sense of
what our interests are that could be
improved if we were moving beyond a
fossil fuel economy I think it's also
the case that as Saudi Arabia tests the
limits of our friendship for example
murdering a journalist who is a u.s.
resident there needs to be some kind of
consequences for that now for the
current president this seems to just be
in dollars and cents relationship to me
it is about American security and it is
about American values and there should
be some sense that we will enforce our
values when they are challenged by a
country that's supposed to be our ally
let alone what we see happening across
the Gulf from a player like Iran if you
were at the United Nations General
Assembly this week as president and you
could meet with only four other world
leaders who would they be well I think
it's time to strengthen our
relationships with European allies and
so either Angela Merkel or manual
McCallum who in many ways I think is
emerging as a kind of successor
generation leader in Central Europe I
think we need to shore that up and have
that conversation so that's one or two
yeah well we'll do 1a and 1b okay we
need to engage with Iran now I wouldn't
do it without some kind of sense that
there was momentum but if our respective
diplomatic relationships could produce
even the smallest incremental
trust-building measure I think that
would justify a conversation about how
we could cause tensions in that region
to go down rather than up that would
require lifting sanctions on Iran II and
leaders so you'd be open to doing that
cuz they say they wouldn't meet with
Americans unless that happens I think we
could find a way if the focus of US
policy were to de-escalate rather than
ratchet up tension oh that's - yeah
we've got 1a 1b in doing
I would like to have a conversation with
the new leader of El Salvador someone
who is I think actually a little bit
younger than I asked great and
represents a part of the country of the
world Central America where we have a
lot at stake first of all the Central
American triangle Guatemala Honduras and
in El Salvador
our countries whose instability is
contributing to issues at our own border
and also countries that are seeking to
stabilize and improve what's happening
there they should have a friend in our
hemisphere in the United States and I'd
like to have a dialogue about how to get
that going okay you got one more well I
think we'd better increase the rate of
conversation we're having with Xi
Jinping the China challenge is going to
be one of the dominant issues for the
United States in my lifetime as I
mentioned at the debate the president
said he would like to see me negotiate
with Xi Jinping I'd like to see him
produce a deal with Xi Jinping but since
it hasn't happened I think we need to
have a very frank conversation about
ways in which we will adjust the future
of the relationship and that may include
an orderly decoupling of some of our
technological interdependencies because
they have very different values they're
developing their technology according to
very different values including
different ideas about surveillance and
the relationship technologically that we
have could become a u.s. security
vulnerability this is not just about
trade this is about technology security
and stability I heard you say on the bus
yesterday you're working on your final
budget proposal back home in South Bend
the other issue of course that through a
lot of your attention drew a lot of
attention from across the country over
the summer was the situation with the
police shooting it's been about three
months what's how has that situation
evolved and in your view or things in a
better place in your city than they were
then you know the pain that we went
through as a community as a consequence
of that situation has led to a very
constructive dialogue about the future
of policing in the community it's
prompted us to look at new ways to give
community members of voice in the way
policy decisions are made
everything from the use of force to the
use of body-worn cameras and even as
information is still being gathered in
the outside investigation of that
particular incident we know that we
didn't have to wait in order to act as a
community and work to build trust there
will continue to be major challenges
around race and policing in our city and
I think in any diverse urban city in
America and it's all the more reason why
we need not only local leadership to
deal with this but also a national
environment that helps reverse the
disempowerment of communities of color
and especially when it comes to police
the relationship with black Americans
that's partly about policing but also
largely about deep questions of
institutional racism that impact housing
health and economic opportunity you're
still struggling to build support among
black and Latino voters in this country
if they get asked about you or they see
you and they think oh you know
interesting that he's young interesting
that he's a military veteran but you
know you know white guy he doesn't
understand our situation and there was a
police shooting in his town just like
there isn't every other scene in this
country I don't know there's got to be
somebody better than that what's your
argument to them why should they be
looking at you right now as a potential
president first of all I've put forward
the most comprehensive plan of any
candidate on dealing with systemic
racism in this country and it's
motivated not just by the conversations
I've been having as a candidate but by
the experience of leading a diverse city
that has these challenges as a
consequence not only of local dynamics
but what's going on around the country
it won't get fixed without national
leadership and our plans about
everything from increasing
entrepreneurship in the black community
to making sure we deliver equity and
health and put an end things like excuse
me the maternal mortality yeah are very
well received because they are among the
most comprehensive ideas put forward on
this issue the other thing that I think
is important is for all of us who have
experienced some kind of exclusion to be
allies at a time like this
each candidate brings a different
experience in a different story
forward I don't have the experience of
being a black American I don't have the
experience of talking to a teenage son
about what to do when you were pulled
over by a police officer I can assume if
I am walking in a department store and
I'm fidgeting with something in my
pocket that I will be given the benefit
of the doubt and not followed I don't
have those personal experiences but I do
have the experience of belonging to a
group that has been feared hated and
denied opportunity in this country and
while those aren't the same it's one of
the reasons I'm powerfully motivated to
ensure that nobody is denied opportunity
in this country because of who they are
you are a gay man you are now ranked at
least fourth in Iowa and you're doing
pretty well nationally has the history
or the historic nature of what you're
doing set in yet it's certainly moving
when people of different ages come up to
me at campaign events
high schoolers who let me know that I've
made it easier for them to get through
their day people my parents age with
tears in their eyes who did not think
something like this was ever going to be
possible in their lifetime and so I'm
very conscious that that there's a
historic quality to this campaign and at
the same time it's important to me that
no one element of my story defined me
this is part of who I am just like the
fact that I'm a veteran and the fact
that I'm a mayor the fact that I'm young
and the fact that I come from northern
Indiana and taken together they add up
to a story that I hope explains why I'm
motivated to lead America into a new
sense of belonging as well as a better
set of policies for our future